la soirée commence dans une atmosphère
festive hier à nantes place royale on
trinque on dans son rythme d'une fanfare
locale à minuit l'apéro géant organisé
via facebook rassemble neuf mille
personnes des nantais mais pas seulement
au fait pourquoi bientôt à ce genre de
manifestation pour la fête pour ce
contrôle entre amis un point voire
amstaff heures en plein air il ya du
monde et une bonne ambiance c'est le
bonheur ça boit beaucoup
écoute c'est l'apéro c'est au nez au jus
d'orange
une soirée a priori conviviale mais qui
va vite dégénérer
la fête se transforme rapidement en
beuverie pompiers secouristes
interviennent 93 fois aux urgences 57
victimes de comas éthyliques
les policiers ont placé 35 personnes en
garde à vue hier à montpellier
un apéro géant était aussi organisé
douze mille personnes au total dans une
ambiance bon enfant certains sont là
juste pour le plaisir
d'autres comptent une raison
particulière de trinquer moi c'est fini
aujourd'hui tous les partis elle donc il
ya aussi je pense que beaucoup de gens
de paul valéry ici et pourquoi pas pour
être avec plein de gens je veux c'est
complètement con comme raisonnement mais
c'est pour être avec des gens mais je ne
sais pas pourquoi il ya une info qui
part de quelqu'un qu'il envoie ses 50
amis chacun de ces 50 amis le diffuse
sur son profil chacun a 50 amis lui
aussi et du coup les gens qui sont
inscrits sur ce genre de site ont tout
de suite l'info peuvent eux mêmes la
diffuser ils sont quinze mille inscrits
sur le groupe facebook mais beaucoup
moins nombreux à venir au rendez vous la
préfecture obtient de l'initiateur
l'annulation de ce qui doit être le plus
grand apéro de france seulement voilà
tout va vite très vite l'idée suit son
chemin une situation incontrôlable qui
surprend les autorités tout de suite
après des gens ont dit non non on
continue quand même des anonymes parce
que sur facebook on est anonyme donc des
gens on peut pas dire qui et qui sait on
dit non non on y va quand même on va
voir où à voir et puis on emmènera nos
bouteilles et puis on amènera nos
copains et puis on fait partager l'info
jadis quand on voulait boire l'apéro
c'était facile comme au village tout le
monde se connaissait ont rameuté les
copains au bistrot et à la tienne
jeannot aujourd'hui
on ne connaît plus dit-on son voisin de
palier mais internet c'est le progrès
nous aide à trouver plein d'amis via les
réseaux sociaux type facebook
l'outil crée du lien c'est bien et
permet pourquoi pas de se donner
rendez-vous pour boire un coup le
problème c'est qu'en ce moment la
tendance est à l'apéro géant à rennes
seront invités les amis des amis pour un
pari faire mieux qu'à nantes 3000
personnes
une sorte de guerre des bouchons il
était pourtant entre 5000 et 8000
jusqu'à 3 heures cette nuit un vrai
moment de convivialité pour les
étudiants en 3ème université ce matin
quand c'était sympa les gens se sont
retrouvés et puis tu vois là savaient
rien non plus d'extraordinaire mais
c'était assez rigolo une utilisation de
facebook assez marrante
ça manquait même de musique sinon
c'était pas mal bonne ambiance
cet apéro géant gêne les élus rennais
depuis le début dénonce l'initiative ils
n'ont pas souhaité nous recevoir
aujourd'hui mais persiste via un
communiqué
l'appel à un apéro géant constitue une
incitation à l'ivresse publique que nous
ne pouvons que dénoncer cette démarche
irresponsable et anonyme a donné lieu à
un rassemblement marqué par une
alcoolisation massive sur l'espace
public
rennes ville étudiante qui se dit fier
de sa jeunesse va devoir trouver
rapidement des solutions pour éviter que
le fossé ne se creuse avec ces jeunes
un appel à un apéro géant le 12 mai à
d'ores et déjà été lancés sur facebook
dans toutes les grandes villes de france
une simple invitation sur le site
internet facebook et voilà ce que ça a
donné hier soir à clermont-ferrand
ils appellent ça un apéro géant 6000
jeunes réunis pour boire un verre chez
nous l'apéro on prend à l'aise l'apéro
donc on installe le terrain pur malaise
toi bien d'aller travailler quoi canapé
l'allemagne et compagnie tout à l'heure
les internautes avaient appelé à un
rassemblement responsable même si
l'alcool coulait à flots aucun incident
majeur n'a été constaté
c'est juste pour passer ou non
responsable en laye sonoco alcore ce
n'était pas dit mais clairement hier
soir à brest
chacun espérait battre un record mon âge
est en fait de bonnes rennes bien mais
je ne sais pas franchement je sais pas
5000 à rennes 7000 ici brest détient
désormais la palme d'un mouvement récent
spontanée et festif bah c'est une bonne
ambiance et puis ça permettrait de se
retrouver avec beaucoup de gens qu'on
n'aurait peut-être pas vu dans d'autres
soirées ou des choses comme ça être
ensemble devient une fin en soi
et les rares musiciens ont bien du mal à
se faire entendre ont causé en bois
l'alcool ici coule à flot et c'est bien
le problème
on dit pas qu'on va pas boire jusqu'à
voilà on a prévu de passer des soirées
ici tranquillement sans énervement
entre amis à essayer de découvrir
peut-être d'autres personnes peut-être
des gens qui sont là pour se battre pour
devenir taper sur les autres mais bon
nous nous on est là pour rigoler c'est
pas un appel consommation aussi non pas
chacun vient si vous consommez y
consomme qu'un appel à la consommation
c'est vraiment chacun fait ce qui lui
plaît
face à ce phénomène les autorités sont
désarmés et ne peuvent qu accompagner
médiateur pour les conseils de sécurité
centre de secours pour les ivresses et
les blessures la fête elle doit être
possible après la fête elles se
préparent elles se préparent elles se
gère avec des organisateurs c'est toute
la difficulté c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'organisateur la feta lancé moi ce qui
me pose question c'est vraiment ça c'est
quand on appuie sur un petit bouton et
puis on fait venir 7000 personnes avec
les dégâts que ça peut provoquer au
final les incidents était étonnamment
faible une quarantaine d'interventions
du poste médical et 5 évacuation vers
les hôpitaux
la fête c'est fini vers 5h sur un bien
triste spectacle
[Musique]